Sorry das ist wirklich der hammer seit mehr als 60 jahren sind sich forschungs sieben sicher es muss eine super
radiant in festkörpern geben bei diesem phänomen sorgt ein angeregtes atom für die abgabe eines protons
dieses einzige lichtteilchen wiederum löst eine kettenreaktion
aus und ein intensiver lichtblitz entsteht doch niemand konnte das bisher nachweisen oder
beobachten jetzt ist die sensation gelungen klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Vielleicht hat es noch aus dem physikunterricht
auf dem schirm atome gehen in einen angeregten zustand über wenn man ihnen energie zuführt die elektronen werden dann auf ein höheres niveau
angehoben und gehen dann später wieder zurück in ihren alten zustand dabei geben sie ein photon ab also ein lichtteilchen
der zeitpunkt dafür ist überhaupt nicht vorauszusehen und das ganze passiert zufällig anders dagegen bei der sogenannten super
radios hier löst die abgabe eines photons unter bestimmten bedingungen direkt eine art kettenreaktion
aus wenn dann alle atome in diesem bereich die überschüssige energie abgeben und das innerhalb weniger sekunden entsteht ein
intensiver lichtblitz das besondere hierbei ein
einziges photon reicht aus um diesen super allianz auszulösen klingt eigentlich eigentlich ganz easy und tatsächlich bereits in den 50er jahren
wurde bereits dieses phänomen vorhergesagt in der theorie jetzt ist es einem forschungsteam aus der schweiz erstmals
gelungen dies auch bei einem festkörper in einem experiment zu zeigen dazu andreas ankara einer der beteiligten forscher
super radiant ist nur dann möglich wenn man die atome in einem bereich versammelt der deutlich kleiner ist als die wellenlänge
der photon
problematisch hierbei sind die atom wechselwirkungen in diesem bereich von wenigen hundert nanometern die die super asiens behindern um das zu umgehen
setzte das forschungsteam auf spezielle diamanten
bestehend aus kohlenstoff gittern mit fehlstellen konkret handelt es sich um
sogenannte light reading vacancy gitter fehler bei denen statt eines
kohlenstoffatoms 1 stickstoff atom eine stelle im gitter besetzt und die stelle daneben unbesetzt bleibt um eine super allianz auszulösen
müssen diese gitter fehler angeregt werden denn sie reagieren besonders ausstrahlung mit besonders großer wellenlänge wie
beispielsweise mikrowellen dazu angerer unser system hat den entscheidenden vorteil dass wird dort mit
elektromagnetischer strahlung arbeiten können die eine wellenlänge von mehreren zentimetern hat daher ist es kein problem
die einzelnen defekt stellen im radius einer wellenlänge zu konzentrieren und tatsächlich das experiment war
erfolgreich die energie der mikrowellen pulse wurde von den guitar fehlern aufgenommen und das system geriet in einen meter
stabilen zustand doch erst als eine bestimmte schwelle erreicht war
reagierten die gitter fehler
309 sekunden
dauerte es nach der mikrowellen abschaltung als dann endlich aus dem zentrum des diamanten ein
photonen blitz hervorschoss dazu heißt es in der aktuellen studie dieser supra die ans pult wurde eine million mal schneller
emittiert als bei der normalen entladung eines
night raw janeway kensy gitter fehler und das ist ein riesenerfolg für das forschungsteam denn somit haben sie dieses schon so lang
vorhergesagte quantenphänomene auch
experimentell in einem festkörper bewiesen und nicht nur das auch für sehr praktische anwendungen könnte das bald
riesige fortschritte bedeuten
dazu ankara super radial spielt in der optik eine prominente rolle wo es beispielsweise die entwicklung von neuen lesern mit super dünnen strahl
ticken ermöglicht unsere arbeit liefert nun die grundlage für zukünftige
quantentechnologie
darunter auch super radiant feststoff laser das finde ich wirklich hammer wie die kanten für sie ganz praktischen nutzen bringt und dadurch nahezu
unmögliche dinge möglich werden wir stehen wirklich vor einem zeitalter
unfassliche sensationelle entwicklung denn durch solche entdeckungen werden
kettenreaktionen ausgelöst werden wie in diesem beispiel zum beispiel erstmal laser mit superdünnen laserstrahlen entwickelt können damit wieder ganz neue
strukturen gefertigt werden aus denen dann
vollkommen neue teile und werkzeuge gefertigt werden können die dann und so weiter und so fort ja und hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
laserschwert bald wirklichkeit
licht wird wie materie und wenn ihr kein video mehr zu diesen und
in anderen themen verpassen wollt dann folgt mir auf whatsapp nur da bekommt ihr von mir
vor allen anderen das neueste video ganz unabhängig von der abo box hier auf youtube die ja bei vielen nicht so ganz perfekt
funktioniert und gerne auch ein abo da lassen und natürlich nicht die
die glocke vergessen bis dann
bleibt dran